[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to a first retail unboxing and
second look at the 2020 motorola
razer so their folding phone is finally
out and starting to ship to buyers and
this is the unboxing experience that
anyone who pays that 1500
will eventually get
so this is it this is the motorola razer
now as a refresher we first got a look
at this guy a couple months ago when it
was first revealed and i did that
hands-on video in the world's worst
hands-on area good times it got delayed
a little bit now 2020 and we've gotten
to the official launch date and they're
trickling out into stores and starting
to ship them so now that it's in hand
now that the shiny new factor has worn
off a little bit i can't help but wonder
and maybe it's because i'm not as
nostalgic but
is this phone or is this form factor
even a good idea to begin with so here's
a refresher we have a 6.2 inch plastic
oled display a little taller than 1080p
so it's 2142 by 876 with that 21 by 9
aspect ratio
snapdragon 710 processor 6 gigabytes of
ram 128 gigs of storage and one
very satisfying hinge
so
yeah it's a folding phone in case i
haven't mentioned that yet and holding
this thing in the hand again i'm
reminded how thin this phone really is
and how complex the hinge mechanism is
i mean we knew it was complex but it's
really very unique and generally ends up
giving you less of a crease than say the
galaxy fold because of the way the
display bends down into the frame and
then unfolds and stretches which is
really smart it bends taut over the
middle keeps it flat but also there's a
moment during the folding process where
you can see like straight through
behind the back of the display which is
potentially interesting for durability
we'll have to keep an eye on that and of
course tune into the inevitable j-rig
everything test also one-handedness is
something i always talk about in
smartphones as they get bigger and
bigger and with this one it's a
multi-part answer so when it's open
i think it's perfectly one handable so
you can reach the corners you can get
down to the bottom of the display it's
not super uncomfortable now it is a bit
different than normal because you have a
hinge in the middle and you can feel it
and there's all sorts of ridges and
bumps along the sides in the back while
you're holding it so it does feel
different from a normal phone but you
can still reach what you need to thanks
to the narrower aspect ratio it's not
too bad
but then
i absolutely cannot open the phone with
one hand or at least i wouldn't want to
like this in everyday life maybe it's
the shape of my finger i don't know what
it is but
that means every time i want to open the
phone or at least get past that outside
screen you need to have two hands free
i don't know if that's going to get
annoying yet but that's just the truth
for me right now which brings me to just
my general overlying question which is
of all the ways to do a folding phone is
this way the 6.2 inch screen but folds
in half to be more pocketable is this
the best way to do it like i know not
everyone can say this but i can already
fit a phone around 6.2 inches in my
pocket just fine but even if you can't
at the moment the choices between
getting a phone that folds in half
versus just getting a slightly smaller
phone i think i would rather have a fold
to enable putting something in my pocket
that i couldn't before like a seven inch
or an eight inch screen like an ipad
mini like a small tablet size this to me
is just a normal sized phone getting
even smaller which is more pocketable
sure but
but this is the razer and so it's got to
look like the iconic razer in fact
that's basically what motorola told me
is they first picked the iconic razer
design and then went to engineering to
try to figure out what they could fit in
this crazy thin form factor in order to
achieve
this razor not the other way around so
that's why we have this crazy cool thin
design but also why we have some of the
crazy specs and the weird compromises
that's why the battery cells are split
into two parts to keep the weight of
this flip phone fairly even not too top
heavy not too bottom heavy and then this
thinness means you're combining those
two cells for a total
a total of just over 2 500 million
powers that's very small it's also why
the buttons are so thin you know the
power and volume buttons on one side
they can't be much thicker than they are
or they wouldn't fit on the phone
and this design is why you ended up with
the chin the original razor had the
iconic chin and the curve gently to that
chin so that you could flip it out and
it was natural looking so this new razor
also has that curve
and it puts as many of the electronics
as it can in that chin like the display
drivers the fingerprint reader and the
downward facing speaker and this phone
also maxes out at 15 watts charging
which normally isn't considered really
fast but
then again the battery's so small that
that's actually debatable
no wireless charging too thin for that
no sim card only e-sim and no expandable
storage no dust or water resistance i
mean don't get me wrong it's definitely
still an impressive phone the folding
display mechanism is this wild
engineering that you've ended up with to
have less of a crease but you know
there's two sides of every coin but you
know what the real question is does it
end the call
when you slam it shut and i guess
there's only one way to find out
is to connect them
and just
end the call
and it does
so i i mean i guess
that's
worth it i don't know it's 1500 bucks
there really is only one way to find out
if it's worth it or not and that is to
use it so that's what i'm going to do
i'm going to daily drive the razor i'm
going to use this as my phone
for a while if you want to follow along
with how this goes that'll be over on
twitter so that'll be updates on things
like battery life how well durability
ends up being camera quality and
probably just some rants sprinkled in
there but more importantly let me know
in the comments what you want to see in
the full review i know cnet just did a
robot folding it and unfolding it
thousands of times i won't be doing that
also because we didn't really see that
actually demonstrate the durability of
the galaxy fold so i don't see why it
would work on other folding phones but
what else do you want to see actually
talked about maybe it's battery life
maybe it's camera quality maybe it's the
ratio between using that outside display
for notification management versus the
inside screen
all of that i'm curious for your
comments and we'll get to that pretty
soon catch you guys in the next video
thanks for watching
see you soon
peace